[Musica]
Quanti di voi passano meno di tre ore al
giorno al telefono meno
Wow dovete insegnarci qualcosa per
insegnarmi qualcosa e quanti di voi
passano più di tre ore al giorno al
telefono
ecco E per curiosità quanti vorrebbero
spendere meno tempo al telefono
Ecco sicuramente Anch'io sono dei vostri
Il mio nome è Michela Ho 23 anni vivo
all'estero dal 2018 studia
all'Università di Amsterdam e in media
passo 6 ore al giorno al telefono
mi piacerebbe dirvi che queste sei ore
sono tutte passate in maniera produttiva
io con i social ci lavoro quindi
dovrebbe essere così ma la realtà un po'
diversa metà del mio tempo è buttato a
guardare video su Tik Tok storie di
Instagram e a leggere i commenti di
persone che litigano sotto gli articoli
di Repubblica
mi cerco di consolare dicendomi che alla
fine qualcosa lo imparo dai social media
per esempio
nelle ultime settimane ho iniziato a
fare l'uncinetto
ho visto un video su Tik Tok di una
ragazza che si è rifatta l'armadio con
l'uncinetto poi Ne ho visto uno
ovviamente sono diventata un target ne
ho visti 150 dopo E allora detto dai lo
faccio anche io Peccato che non abbiano
mostrato questi video le ore di lavoro e
gli anni di apprendimento che ci
vogliono per farsi un vestito o un
cardigan e adesso ho a casa piena di
gomitoli di lana e sciarpe mezze finite
Questa è l'unica che ho finito ed è
sinceramente bruttissima forse la prima
fila la vedete Ma le ultime la vedete
ancora un po' più carina ma da vicino è
veramente piena di errori
quando mi hanno chiesto di venire a
parlarvi di futuro non ero così sicura
di che cosa raccontare Io faccio parte
di quella generazione la Z che è
tristemente famosa per la sua incertezza
quindi di futuro non ne so così tanto
poi però ho pensato a come il futuro si
ispira sempre al presente e ha come il
nostro presente prenda forma anche dai
social media
io con i social media lavoro dal 2019
quando per gioco ho iniziato una pagina
chiamata spaghetti politics dove
raccontavo di politica italiana in
inglese ai miei compagni di corso oggi
spaghetti politics a quasi 240 mila
followers mi ha permesso di trovare dei
lavori mi ha permesso di viaggiare e
persino di scrivere un libro che
ironicamente si chiama il futuro non può
aspettare
quindi ho avuto la possibilità tramite
la pagina e tramite la mia vita
all'estero di confrontarmi con
moltissimi giovani miei coetanei e mi
sono resa conto che sia tra gli italiani
sia che tra gli stranieri Esiste un
diffuso sentimento di incertezza e di
inadeguatezza
Paradossalmente i social ci hanno dato
la possibilità di conoscere il mondo
oltre ogni limite immaginabile ma allo
stesso tempo ci fanno sentire anche più
soli
Chi di voi si sente un po' più solo
quando utilizza i social immagino
qualcuno di voi sicuramente
sui social O almeno sullo schermo tutti
sembrano sempre più felici più belli
anche più ricchi e quindi di ricambio
nasce un sentimento di inadeguatezza
scrolli il feed di Instagram e tra le
foto di un bombardamento a Gaza e una
news devastante sul cambiamento
climatico Vedi foto di corpi scolpiti
immagini di vacanza Santorini la notizia
su quella che si è laureata in tempi
record che i giornali ogni ciclicamente
ripropongono e addirittura foto di
persone che hanno appena comprato casa e
Posano con le chiavi in mano e magari tu
sei lì alle 10:30 di sera a letto dopo
una giornata Dove senti di non aver
concluso niente magari è procrastinato
tutto il giorno e allora cosa fai spegni
il telefono e vai a dormire
nell'ultimo periodo personalmente sto
facendo molta fatica ad utilizzare la
mia pagina Instagram infatti la uso
sempre meno
Cioè chi mi dice Ma dai ma la devi
sfruttare economicamente e invece c'è
chi mi dice guarda i social sono il male
fai benissimo devi abbandonarla la
verità che sento una forte dissonanza
tra la mia vita di tutti i giorni e la
mia vita on line
da un lato l'università la tesi
l'incubo di dover pensare a cosa fare
una volta laureata
dall'altro
l'alienazione da queste preoccupazioni
il bombardamento in sequenza di migliaia
di notizie di persone di opinioni che mi
fanno sentire più sicura mi fanno
sentire al rifugio di conseguenza queste
due emozioni contrastanti mi fanno
sentire incerta
poi devo dire che il mondo esterno Non è
che aiuta molto nel senso Uno leggere
notizie vede il mondo sembra il collasso
il cambiamento climatico avanza sempre
di più Si parla di ansia e di eco ansia
giustamente e quindi Social poi
diventano un luogo per nascondersi una
ricerca condotta nel Regno Unito nel
2009 da Princess Trust ha evidenziato
come tra i ragazzi tra i 16 e 25 anni
nel 2009 il 9% di loro sentisse che non
valeva la pena di vivere la propria vita
al numero Altissimo nel 2019 questo
numero era raddoppiato è arrivato al 18%
è un numero ancora più alto e stiamo
parlando di numeri pre-pandemia quindi
chissà ora a che punto siamo
crescere in una società dove ci si sente
così incerti e dove per esempio il mondo
del lavoro non è più quello dei nostri
genitori o dei nostri nonni ma ci si
comporta ancora come se lo fosse come se
in fondo al tunnel dello stage non
pagato della laurea sudata e magari
anche fuori corso e della famosa Gavetta
ci fosse la sicurezza di una vita
standard che però non c'è e lo sappiamo
bene
Ma quando noi analizziamo tutte queste
ricerche tutti questi dati perché di
ricerche ne sono uscite tante negli
ultimi anni che ci dimostrano come i
social media facciano male si fanno
sentire più soli più ansiosi come
abbiamo già detto Ma siamo sicuri che
sia davvero solo colpa dei social
cresciamo Almeno così è stato per me in
una società dove le nostre tappe sono
distinte molto bene fino a 18 anni
quindi dopo ogni scuola se ne sussegue
un'altra e ogni anno c'è la
consapevolezza che il settembre dopo ci
si siederà di nuovo sui banchi di fianco
ai propri amici poi però Arriva la
quinta liceo Le quinta superiore che per
me è stata un po' traumatica Quindi
arrivi 18 anni per la prima volta di
fronte a te non sai cosa succederà
L'anno dopo però sei consapevole che
quella scelta ti cambierà in qualche
modo la vita
io l'università Olanda L'ho scelta molto
a caso Devo essere onesta ho scelto un
posto che mi piaceva era numero aperto
non mi dovevo stressare troppo però mi è
andata benissimo ho trovato la mia vita
mi sono costruita il mio futuro diciamo
non è sempre così
diventare adulti in questa società dove
il terreno sotto i nostri piedi sembra
cambiare costantemente può essere molto
difficile
cresciamo Almeno in questo momento della
mia vita io mi sento così tirata da due
forze opposte una è la forza della
ricerca della mia individualità che però
viene resa sempre più difficile
dall'imposizione di modelli da parte dei
social media della società in generale
L'altra invece è la forza della società
tradizionale dei genitori dei nonni che
vogliono farti ricalcare dei modelli
Ormai in via d'estinzione
Eppure una soluzione Paradossalmente a
questo sentimento di incertezza ed
inadeguatezza c'è
la pausa
è normale vivere in una società dove gli
si vive la pausa quasi con un senso di
colpa dove mentre io mi prendo una pausa
dal lavoro Ho l'ansia di dover
ricominciare o se sono a casa a non fare
nulla Mi sento in produttiva mi sento in
colpa non è tanto normale e non è
neanche normale dire una frase come mi
prendo una pausa dai Social me li
cancello per un paio di mesi quanti miei
amici lo dicono e poi se li ritirò poi
se li scaricano non è normale prendersi
una pausa da un'attività che di per sé
nasce come pausa e che diventa così
assillante da richiedere un controllo
sono state in Olanda negli ultimi 5 anni
e ho avuto la possibilità di
confrontarmi con tanti compagni Nord
europei il Nord Europa è molto comune
l'hanno sabbatico dopo le superiori o
dopo la triennale è quasi accettato
universalmente che lo studente vada a
fare un anno sabbatico un anno di
viaggio di solito un anno dove si sta a
casa si seguono i propri interessi in
Italia è difficilissimo fare un anno
sabbatico la società fa molta fatica ad
accettarlo
spesso viene visto come un anno
improduttivo un anno dove non si fa
nulla perché è risaputo che viaggiare
fare esperienze non insegna
assolutamente nulla eh io personalmente
ho fatto un anno sabbatico l'ho fatto
l'anno scorso dopo la mia triennale sono
stata in Francia per sei mesi dove ho
lavorato per una Ong con il corpo di
solidarietà europeo che è un po' il
servizio civile ma versione Unione
Europea a cosa mi è servito questo anno
questo sei mesi sabbatici a capire di
non volere mai lavorare in una Ong cioè
io prima pensavo che la Ong fosse una
carriera nel mio futuro fosse qualcosa
che mi interessava il funzionamento la
comunicazione
Meno male che ho fatto questa esperienza
e non ho proseguito in degli Studi che
mi avrebbero preparata solo a quella
carriera perché poi me ne sarei pentita
e grazie a questi sei mesi ho capito che
forse la mia strada era un'altra e
infatti poi ho scelto una magistrale che
mi permetteva di fare qualcos'altro
tra i tanti dei miei amici moltissimi
hanno fatto un anno sabbatico penso una
delle mie migliori amiche Sheila una
ragazza tedesca lei ha fatto un anno
sabbatico prima dell'università è stata
un'anima in America Latina da sola se
l'è viaggiata tutta in piedi a piedi in
autobus in treno in autostop di
settimana in settimana cambiava
lavoretto in ostello in fattoria
Veramente anche in fattoria o per
qualsiasi posto che va bisogno di una
mano lei andava in cambio di Vitto
alloggio magari qualche mancetta in
questo modo è riuscita a viaggiare
senza chiedere supporto esterno ed ha
imparato tantissime cose
L'ultima volta che ho visto Sheila è
stata a ottobre ero a casa sua Stuttgart
e lei si stava preparando a tre mesi di
viaggio senza meta aveva appena finito
di lavorare tre mesi in una fabbrica
della Mercedes
dove aveva guadagnato abbastanza per
potersi permettere i termini successivi
e l'ultima volta che l'ho sentita Era
capodanno ed era in Marocco Quindi ha
scelto di fare un tour del Nord Africa
senza però un viaggio preciso
lei non è l'unica tanti altri lo fanno
fanno volontariato come per esempio ho
fatto io con un Ong c'è chi torna
semplicemente a casa che non è male
anche sono tornata a casa per un paio di
mesi devo dire anche senza fare nulla
tornare dopo tanti anni in cui vedevo i
miei genitori solo per un paio di
weekend all'anno è stato molto bello
Come possiamo vivere in una società dove
non siamo non ci viene permesso di
prenderci una pausa di Esplorare i
nostri interessi di scoprire chi siamo
quando noi guardiamo sui social media
quello che vediamo è finto è l'illusione
della certezza Come possiamo pensare al
futuro in una società che è così
radicata in un presente che esiste solo
fuori dalla nostra portata non è
possibile però se guardiamo i social Se
guardiamo internet l'immagine dell'umano
modello 2023 è il gran lavoratore però è
sempre in vacanza è quello che mangia
sempre fuori pranzo cena possa sempre le
foto però è sempre magro sempre bello è
sempre impegnato quindi è sempre fare le
trasferte di lavoro è sempre fuori con
gli amici però è anche sempre al lavoro
sempre costantemente super impegnato
Come è possibile non è possibile sono
delle contraddizioni sono delle
illusioni
prenderci una pausa in una società che
dà il nostro valore in base alla nostra
produttività la nostra efficienza e la
nostra apparenza è l'atto più radicale
che possiamo permetterci
[Applauso]